foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's Sunday
yep hopefully you guys are having an
enjoyable weekend so far I know it's
almost over but you know what I mean
we're reviewing a classic classic sounds
of classic yeah we watched it like
several days ago when we just didn't get
around to because I think we were
supposed to review it like last Tuesday
but I was just like too wrecked to do it
so I was like well we'll save it for
Sunday when I've seen it in a long time
this is probably about the fourth time
I've seen it and uh it's good I forgot
how good it is
um it's not an action movie in some ways
it's kind of slow if you're expecting an
action movie It's called Gattaca but
it's very interesting about a society
that is where most of the people are
genetically engineered now
and uh how it affects Society
and they got this guy
who
basically by dumb luck because his
parents didn't want to do it he wasn't
genetically engineered but his younger
brother was the one that came out after
him and he was able to do all kinds of
stuff just on the basis of his DNA
and he's relegated to being a janitor he
wants to be an astronaut though they
made him a janitor and because they
treat you if you're not genetically
engineered they treat you as as like
you're handicapped basically yeah even
though technically they do actually make
the thing to say in the movie that
technically it's not legal yeah to do
that to discriminate but they do it
anyway yeah like everybody does it
anyway yeah they use they use
technicalities they're like well we
can't insure these people
so we can't bring them in the job
because they can't be insured against
you know health insurance the same way
and liability and accident insurance so
they're too much of a risk
for a real desirable jobs
and you know it's funny because
like if if you show up for a job and
you're dependent on your your uh
your resume to get the job you're You're
Gonna Lose
because the guys who actually get the
job just take a single blood sample and
they go okay yeah you're good you're
good because they know that you've
already got like the best genes possible
for intelligence and you know the way
you look in your health
so you're physically genetically
Superior
to a person who is an engineered
so they're going to get all the first
picks of the jobs
and it's a real kind of
quiet
classy environment because all the Riff
Raff's been [__] weeded out it's
mostly just the superior people
and uh but it's sterile and this guy's
trying to become an astronaut
and he figures out a way where he can
fake his blood and his urinalysis and
that stuff to get in there and that's
really where the movie kind of starts
and there's a bunch of lessons in the
movie you know philosophical lessons
about your limitations it's good though
real good well yeah I kind of feel like
the whole theme of the movie uh the cool
thing about the movie I feel like a lot
of people
this came out in 1997 and I think I saw
it in the theater I'm pretty sure I saw
it in the theater and I was like wow
that was really good and I saw it a
couple times subsequently it didn't do
very well at the box office it cost like
36 million to make I don't even think it
made half its budget back I think it
came in like fifth place like in the in
its first week people just really didn't
resonate with it I guess um in the 90s
sci-fi was maybe a lot more flashy or a
lot more this was a lot more this is
kind of like more like a Noir film yeah
in a science fiction context yeah the
the it's structured like a Noir film and
there's like a murder mystery aspect to
it also and it's Detective
uh yeah the The
Motif The stylistic Motif is kind of
like late 50s early 60s yeah it's like
retro future yeah it's futuristic but
everything looks like the cars look like
something out of the 50s or the city
yeah they're based on like old 60s cars
which I thought was cool I like the
whole look of it they're all classy and
[__] and leather interiors but they're
Electric
or something I guess they're Electric
um
and then you know they have real high
technology but you don't really notice
it because everything's kind of just
like very decorative and and the
technology is very minimal very very
small
and minimalize they have laptops not
yeah laptops don't they or they people
yeah sort of they're like PCS yeah they
don't seem to have any mobile devices no
they don't but they don't really need it
need them I guess they hadn't thought
about it for the movie but in the story
they're not they're not really needed
um
it's got a real good cast the acting is
very good I know why this didn't make
any money I mean
it's a well-made movie well crafted it's
uh it's well thought out it's a
beautiful looking yeah a beautiful
sounding movie the score is great
Michael nyman did the score actually but
yeah the score is really good but it's a
just the the look of it is just like
really gorgeous yeah I think probably
the reason why people it didn't it
didn't really catch on it's not an
action movie it's one of the reasons why
it's a character piece like more like a
Noir movie like yeah if you like Blade
Runner you'd like this yeah slasher Fred
just mentioned Blade Runner like
consider that also has a nor feeling
with Decker narrating yeah yeah this
also has narration and it's very I was
watching another review of it and they
said that this movie is very Earnest
like it takes itself very so like a norm
movie would it's not like winking at the
audience it's not funny it's not like
some of the um I don't know it just
seems like a movie that would have come
out like in the 40s or 50s and that was
a very deliberate like that tone of it
um but in a more like modern sterile
whole setting and I think that really
worked for me like I really really like
that but I can see how maybe some people
like thought it was weird or off-putting
or something like that because like I
said it's not real it's not like a high
action movie it's more like a it's
actually kind of more like an
allegorical
movie well there's a bunch of lessons
about materialism and right superficial
apparently but I think another reason
why it may be alienated uh the might
have alienated audiences is because
the main character is just a normal guy
and he's surrounded by
authority figures who are superior
they're not faking that they're Superior
they are superior they're genetically
they're genetically engineered they're
better yeah than you are they're
stronger they're faster they're smarter
they're better looking they live longer
they're a lot more healthier than you
they can smoke and drink to their hearts
desire and they'll never get sick uh
they're they're better than than a
normal human
so I think that kind of turns a lot of
people off you know I mean the idea of
genetic engineering and and Supremacy it
bothers people but that's the point of
this movie okay without that this movie
doesn't work
this guy is able to kind of through
basically willpower
he's able to compete against these
people because he wanted it because he
wanted it yeah the thing about it what's
cool what's the cool message about this
movie is that despite all of these
people being like you said they are
objectively genetically Superior yeah to
uh you know Ethan Hawke's character
whose name is Vincent but there's limits
to that and it might gets into that and
the movie gets into that because those
people in a lot of ways and you can kind
of make a um a parallel too with like
people who are born very wealthy or
something like that they just have
everything handed to them they don't
really have to work hard for anything
it's easy for them it's easy for them
and they so they don't really have the
passion and the drive to like overcome
adversity the way that someone like
Vincent would have to who is you know
genetically inferior he was just natural
born in a world where most people are
genetically engineered so he had to
struggle and strive and work harder for
everything that he wanted
um you know and the genetically Superior
people never had to do that right they
don't take rejection as well yeah like
okay one of the characters is a he was
just born to be he's played by Jude Law
he's funny I love Jude Law super
handsome super intelligent super witty
and he's this the best [__] swimmer
you could [__] imagine right but he
competes and he gets a silver he came in
second came in second not first because
guess what everybody is a superior
swimmer yeah they can't control luck
yeah okay so he attempts suicide but he
fails and it puts him in a damn
wheelchair yeah he [__] his legs off
yeah and a bunch of [__] so even though
you could be genetically objectively
Superior
It's Not Really Gonna help you that much
because you can't control luck
and if you're genetically Superior so
are all your peers so there's no
advantage
you don't have an advantage over them
yeah because everybody everybody the
best right
so it's like you're just you're just
like you're vaulting yourself into just
like another conversation so what ends
up happening is you end up becoming even
though you're genetically Superior
amongst your peers you're just mundane
yeah because everybody's awesome because
everybody's office
so that problem comes in they talk about
that
um
and in a way that Jude Law in the air in
the wheelchair helps he's given up his
blood samples and his skin samples to
help uh Victor Vincent Vincent excuse me
Vincent uh to have a fraudulent
identification it passes him so they
switch IDs he's kind of living
vicariously through him because he's
actually seeing somebody who is actually
struggling but winning yeah and he's
becoming more than what he really is the
Jude Law character will never be more
than what he is because he is what he is
and he's already maxed out but so are
all of his friends yeah so he's just
another one there's no dreams no dreams
to that only reality
so it's it's a good flick it's a real
good flick and it's one where you you
can't just watch it
you have to kind of learn from it it
teaches a bunch of lessons in it I was
like I was reading like a review of this
and there was like a lot of comments of
people that were actually
um you know commenting some really
insightful things like about this movie
and one of the things that they pointed
out that I don't think that I ever
thought of when I was watching this
movie was that Jude Law's character his
name is Jerome
um you know would he even you know had
he just been born in the natural way
like nowadays and it's like would he
even have wanted to be an Olympic
swimmer the implication is that his
parents had him genetically engineered
to be and to be one to be like an
athlete to be an Olympic swimmer would
that have been what he had would have
chosen up you know so that's like the
piano player that had the [__] 12 the
12 fingers he was made for that for me
that's all he could and it's like did he
really want to do it that's just kind of
it wasn't his choice yeah and that's
kind of like what they're getting at too
like they don't hit you over the head
with that but I was like oh yeah like
Jude Law might not have like chosen to
be his woman like he might not have
wanted to do that but see the point of
it was that Vincent's character he was
just born regular but he whatever since
he was a kid he wanted to go into space
he wanted to be an astronaut and he
wanted that more than anything and that
actually made him
work harder and like do all this other
stuff and like made him in a way like
because he had to work around his
limitations that other people didn't
have like other people had things given
to them really really easily you know
they could just go in give a drop of
blood they're like okay you can be an
astronaut he had to like find all these
devious ways to like work around the
rules of society so that he could get in
there and once he got in there he was
actually good enough to compete with
them but see he would have never been
given a chance because of his inferior
genetics so he had to like really yeah
invade an identity to get in there and I
forgot he was a normal guy but he
actually had inferior genetics he had a
genetic heart failure genetic heart
defect yeah so that was the point about
what he could have been because they
said when he was born that he had a 90
it was 99
that he would die like before 30 or
something like that but see 99 is isn't
a hundred percent so there's a chance
that he still I mean obviously he was
still alive like he was older than 30.
so but
so I think that was kind of another
underlying message in the movie too is
that nothing is certain is that nothing
is certain even if the people are
genetically engineered because [__] even
the doctor at the end yeah that knew
that he was faking the identity yeah and
was just kind of like I go ahead anyway
because my son I think that his son
wasn't not the doctor son wasn't Natural
Born he was genetically engineered but
he didn't turn out it turned out right
the way that they thought yeah and Uma
Thurman's character yeah um Irene she is
genetically superior but she also has a
heart condition so it's not a perfect
science you're right so that's kind of
another thing that they're saying it's
like even these people that are
genetically engineered they're still
like an element of like you said luck in
there yeah well they can't control fate
because they bad luck you they have bad
luck yeah and then they they don't
really seem to have any control over
their fate like they didn't choose what
they were built for right so what
they're implying is is that they're not
free yeah that they're not really free
that they were purpose built so there's
no choice in any of this
you know what I mean your purpose built
to be a [__] piano player yeah
they're purpose built to be
a [__] swimmer
and when he came in second
because everybody else was just like him
that he was competing against he tried
to kill himself because he realized he
was not free right in a way you know
what I mean it was
everything is stacked against you
because everything is equal and equality
is not about Supremacy
yeah it's about luck and you can't
control luck yeah if everybody's exactly
the same
so yeah that's what I mean so false
Supremacy right when it comes down to it
yeah
um you know Vincent's character who did
not have any of the advantages that they
had was able to work his way in there
and go into space and be an astronaut
and realize his dream just on the just
on the bear you know thing of him
wanting it so bad that he was just
willing and obviously like he had to get
in there and he had to be smart enough
to do all the work and he had to do all
that like otherwise they would have
caught him he was right yeah he's also
as I was gonna say he was also able
to fool them
uh for a long time about who he was and
he was able to evade detection during a
murder investigation yeah and he was a
suspect yeah but he got eliminated later
on but
because imagine the world I mean the
work that he had to go through just to
get into Gattaca like I said and
obviously
um everybody that's genetically
engineered
um you know obviously things are going
to happen to them like they'll get in
accidents or they'll you know Try
Suicide like Jude Law's character did
and he became like um you know he was in
a wheelchair like because he lost the
use of his legs so you know that that
has to happen often enough because there
is a Black Market yeah in what they call
you know a borrowed ladder that's like
when you go and use somebody else's yeah
like their urine and their blood and
their skin Flakes and stuff like that so
you can pass as somebody else so there's
obviously a black market in it that
they're like looking out for so it has
to be like fairly common or Uma Thurman
plays this genetically engineered chick
that he works with
and all the girls in the in the space
program and it looks just like a regular
office they're wearing suits and stuff
and on desks and uh they're doing all
this damn Advanced [__]
physics and Mathematics
and uh all the girls are
infatuated with him you know they don't
they think he's genetically Superior
because he's coming up real high on the
tests you know and he's
way he carries himself they buy it well
they're raid in his workspace with
little vacuum cleaners trying to vacuum
up and find his hair and skin drop skin
cells and just anything so they could
have him analyzed they wanted to see how
good his DNA what really was
and that was something that they did
evidently in this in this world in this
universe
as part of their dating culture yeah
they wouldn't date you until they
actually got a DNA sample from you but
it was kind of you couldn't ask
it was like considered to be rude
so they would try to steal DNA from him
like take a hair out of your comb or one
girl they show like one girl going into
uh you know the place where you do it if
it looked like a one-hour photo type of
situation where you just go in there and
I guess the guy had kissed her and so
they took the DNA his DNA like off her
lips yeah and then like you know she'll
run him through the thing and see what
was going on it's kind of like running a
motherfucker's credit before you want to
go right yeah I mean let's see his
credit score first or you know Googling
him yeah they're gonna Google yeah well
but although I would advise doing that
because you got to find out like you
know you know you don't want them to be
like a sexual predator or something like
that you know what I mean but that's
what they're doing see and uh he knows
all the girls are after him so he's got
to clean up all of his debris that's
falling off his body and he's got to
replace it with Jude Law degree so they
have fingernails and eyelashes and stuff
so he is like really going all in yeah
so they're getting samples and they're
coming back and they're coming back with
Jude Law which what's his name what was
that character's name Jerome Jerome
that's right coming back with Jerome's
DNA results and everything and his
shit's off the charts okay so that there
so um the Uma Thurman's character I
forgot what her name was supposed to
Irene Irene that's right
uh Irene is [__] head over and heels
for him she's doing everything she can
to get her hooks into him and she's got
a badass pad out on the beach and
everything you know and uh
it's just I don't want to spoil it I
mean it's an old movie but she
she eventually finds out that he's not
that he's not genetically engineered
that he's actually [__] up
he's [__] up just like the rest of us
and her mind is blown but she can't
believe that
she can't believe that you know he was
able to pull us off because in this
world that they've that would be the
equivalent
of you being like in on Wall Street and
then you find out
that the guy you're you're you're trying
to date was hiding the fact that he had
Down syndrome that's basically that's
going at what level it was yeah because
they just assumed that I mean if you
were an invalid if you were naturally
born like yeah and Hawk's character was
then basically they were just like well
you got to be a janitor you just got a
clean toilet yeah you're you're if
you're if you're not genetically
engineered you're literally like a Down
syndrome person you're mentally
handicapped yeah that's how they that's
how they treat people yeah like the
difference between a human and a
chimpanzee or something like that like
another species yeah it's like it's like
a caste system is basically what it is
so she can't believes it but she learns
a lesson about love I guess that's the
uh that
it we could just I don't want to ruin
all of it well I mean she gets mad when
she finds out
um you know that he's not who he says he
is when she meets the real Jerome yeah
because you know during the course of
the murder investigation yeah but she's
mad but then you know he's like well I'm
the same person you know that I have
been this whole entire time you know and
you like me then so and you know he has
a heart condition she has a heart
condition so it's like she kind of like
relates to him on that level as well so
I like that in the end she just
um you know he actually like gives her
because it was a whole thing where
um you know she stole one of his hairs
even though it was Jude Law's hair and
she didn't know that to uh like from his
desk and like had him genetically thanks
like she admitted it later she's like
yeah did your your DNA thing
um and she's like here you can do mine
and she pulled her hair out and he was
like oops nope because he was just like
nah I don't care about that I just like
you as a person so I like that at the
end like she did the same thing he was
like look this is who I really am and
gave her a piece of hair and she was
just like oops you know and she just
kind of let it go because she was like
you know I just liked you the way you
were and
yeah you know I don't I don't have to
like know all of that because that's the
thing that they're kind of like
addressing in the movie is
yeah you can have all these genetic
advantages you can have all this kind of
stuff like you can have all this great
potential but that doesn't necessarily
mean that your potential is going to be
realized and that doesn't mean that
somebody that doesn't have all of those
you know all of those advantages can't
like kick ass also because like I said
you know this is really kind of like um
an inspirational story in a lot of ways
because he just
he just wanted it so badly that
he achieved it you know even though he
had to do like I said Not only did he he
had to scrub himself like with wire
brushes and stuff like to get all skin
Flakes and all this other kind of like
hair and [__] like that off him as much
as possible then he had to take little
vials of like Jude laws matter like with
skin Flakes and hair and stuff and like
put that on his desk in case they
vacuumed [__] up and like looking for it
and they were and yeah and well that's
it well especially after because the
stakes got higher because somebody in
the company like got murdered and then
they found like a stray eyelash that
belonged to Jerome well the prolonged to
Vincent Vincent that's right yeah like
his other like his real identity there
was an end there was an invalid in here
yeah so it's like oh that that's clearly
the person that was the murderer yeah
and they're like yeah it couldn't be
there hasn't you know that guy's been
out of the company for a long time
because they had the ID because he used
to work there he was a janitor he's a
janitor there and they're going yeah he
hasn't worked in here in a long time
it's got to be something just blowing
around yeah yeah but that's the thing
it's just kind of like and oh I I forgot
to mention too that
um Jerome the real Jerome was actually
what two inches taller yeah than Vincent
so he actually had to have his legs
broken and he had to like stretch that
so he'd be the same height so he could
pass as that guy yeah but I really my
favorite part about this movie other
than like the look of it
it's just kind of like the the issues
that it raises and like I said it's
almost kind of like an inspirational
kind of movie too but I really like the
relationship between Ethan Hawke's
character and Jude Law's character yeah
because I mean he just basically gets in
with Jerome because like I said there's
a black market and he's like well this
guy kind of they kind of look alike you
know they're kind of the same and he he
could pass as him you know what I mean
so um so at first Jerome is just kind of
like doing this as a business I mean
he's a very cynical
um guy I mean he's depressed it's he was
Superior like I said he came in second
and it's like he couldn't take it
because the weight of expectation was
just like too much for him so he's
basically just like sitting around in
his apartment in his wheelchair just
like smoking all the time smoking and
drinking smoking and drinking and
getting hookers and [__] like that
because he's just like given up on life
pretty much because he didn't live up to
his potential but as The Story Goes On
they actually develop like a really
interesting friendship and it gets to
the point where Jerome
he he almost like starts to like he said
live vicariously through Vincent because
he's like well I can't do anything
anymore but you're going to space and
you're doing it and so he almost gets
like enthusiastic about that like it's
giving him another reason to to live to
live like because he's like I can help
you achieve your dream you know I I'm my
dream is over I can't do anything
anymore but he almost kind of like finds
a temporary like new lease on life like
helping him yeah you know do what he
wants to do and I thought that was like
really cool I really liked the
relationship because the acting with
them is like really really good yeah it
didn't last long though because uh what
ends up happening is that the dude was
just designed to be the best
and he just couldn't be in that
wheelchair any longer yeah so he just
told him he says uh he says because he
says you're going to go off to Titan and
uh when you come back I'm gonna and he's
showing him all this big freezer filled
with [__] urine and blood and bottles
and he goes he goes these are all my
samples here
um enough for you to last a lifetime so
I'll be with you forever and he goes
where you going and he goes I'm going
traveling and he's like oh okay and
again boy went off to fly to Titan
and Jude Locke climbed into the dam
garbage incinerator to set himself on
fire kill himself yeah well he was you
knew he was going to do that the whole
time because he just talked about just
finishing the job because like he said
his his life was over I liked too like
that he gave
Vincent a piece of his hair like because
he was like I wrote you a letter like
don't open it until you're in space like
until you actually did it and there was
like his hair in there so it's almost
like a little piece of him got to go got
to go to Titan right yeah so I thought
that was like kind of cool yeah but um
yeah so I like that ending and I also
like we haven't even talked about the
whole relationship between Vincent and
his brother Anton yeah because Vincent
was born first and his parents were just
like ah [__] it we're not going to get
genetically because people still do that
I don't even think it was religion no
remember he says don't you want God to
have a say in any of this
remember that about selecting what what
DNA that the kid would have should we
shouldn't we leave that up to God oh
yeah maybe yeah I thought they were just
kind of like a bucket but then a couple
years later they changed their mind they
had another kid
and they had they're like they're like
cranked up let's design we're gonna have
a better one because he was having
problems remember he was having heart
problems yeah he couldn't see that well
you know his vision was bad
so his dad was disappointed in him yeah
didn't even give him his name yeah he
was going to name him after himself that
was like so that was really
heartbreaking yeah like that he's like
when he was the baby was born and they
and they told him like with the genetic
predispositions were and he's like um
you know oh we're gonna name him Anton
or Antonio I think
no we'll name him Vincent yeah but then
the second kid that was genetically
engineered he named that one Anthony so
he named him after him yeah because he
figured that one would live longer and
that would be his son yeah and I was
like man that's [__] up Dad it's not a
practical decision in a certain way he
thought that they told him that that kid
wouldn't live very long right
little little did they know though yeah
her statistics didn't work out all the
time
yeah because like I said in control
Destiny or fate is right part of the
thing that's the thing and that's kind
of the thing that it this sort of
alludes to this movie is that you know
with all the science in the world and
all the designer genetics and everything
like that you're never gonna be like a
hundred percent yeah because there's
just too many variables yeah you're not
you can't dictate to to the world in
nature how things will occur yeah it
just it doesn't work that's what I mean
it doesn't almost never come true no go
back and look at scientific predictions
from 50 years ago or 100 years ago
they're ridiculously wrong
you can go back 30 years and the [__]
that they thought would be oh it'll be
around 30 years from now we'll be you
know flying cars right now it doesn't
happen
you can't predict it yeah and that's
just the same thing with this which is
why this kind of like designer engineer
I'm not saying that people aren't going
to start doing Gene editing and stuff
like that because I think they're I
think they're already doing it that's
what I mean I think they're already kind
of doing it yeah but it's never going to
be an exact science because like I said
there's just too many variables and you
can't control the outside world you know
you could make the most Superior genetic
specimen in the world and they could
walk out the street one day and a piano
could fall on them and crush them to
death you know what I mean so it's like
you can't really
they say they say China's doing it but
it's expensive and evidently Rich
couples that can go to China and have a
designer baby made but I think it's
clandestine I don't think it's yeah I'm
not sure it's legal because I mean it is
kind of like a and the thing about it
the thing about this movie in particular
is that they don't
they don't necessarily villainize the
parents for wanting that because the
thing about it is like if you're gonna
have a kid it's not crazy to think oh
well I want my kid to have every
possible advantage in life I don't want
them to get sick I don't want them to
suffer I don't so that's not a bad thing
necessarily but so it's it's like
understandable that people would want to
do that yeah but then it's just kind of
like you know exploring the
ramifications of that like over the long
term yeah and it seems to have happened
with all Races they're white people
Hispanic people and black people in this
movie that are genetically engineered
yeah they just genetically engineer
everybody so they just anybody of the
newer Generations just genetically
engineered I mean they're all real
intelligent and chilled out and it's
like you're talking to a doctor you know
or some kind of professional well I
think that that that was kind of meant
to show that they were essentially
soulless
because like I said they didn't really
have to they didn't have to struggle
like Vincent had to struggle they didn't
have any passion they didn't have you
know they didn't want they were just
like made to do a specific thing and
they were just [__] hot at it and really
good at it they didn't have to try hard
you know they could just do it yeah so
naturally to them right so they didn't
really have they couldn't didn't develop
any kind of like personality quirks or
anything like that so everyone was just
kind of samey I think that's kind of
what they were they were I would I would
I would describe them as they were slick
they were very slick and elegant yeah
all right classy but Jenny's probably
right they were probably generic though
too yeah
um that was kind of the the impression
that I got that it's like everyone was
just so awesome right that they didn't
have to like
variation in the personalities right
they didn't really have to try to do
anything like I said so they didn't
really have to like overcome any kind of
adversity not a unique character there I
guess right right yeah that's what I'm
saying so it's I think that's what they
were I mean this is a very I mean this
was a relatively low budget for a movie
of this type yeah it doesn't look low
budget though it doesn't look low budget
it's actually like really beautiful the
cinematography is really nice and like I
said I really like the retrofuturistic
feel like a Noir feel it makes it feel
very Timeless in a way
but um I place this movie High I play
yeah it's really good and I feel like
it's really underappreciated it's a
forgotten classic now I star cast I feel
like if you like Blade Runner or if you
like something like Moon yeah um this
kind of reminds me of the same kind of
thing as moon baby it's not exactly the
same but it's the same kind of vibe I
guess a great performance by Earnest
[__] board now Ernest it's not
a huge role but yeah no but he's good he
does he does he shows up and he goes you
know you want to go to space start by
cleaning this space right over here it's
one of the janitors he was he was always
like the manager of the Janet yeah he
was an old guy before genetic
engineering and they gave him the job of
just running the janitors the
non-engineered janitors and you know he
was just resigned to his fate yeah
keep dreaming you're not going to space
yeah it's like that it's like where it's
not that's not for us that's not for us
right yeah yeah this actually has a
great cast yeah Alan Arkin is in it he
plays like one of the detectives when
you know when the murder investigation
happens gorvadol is in this yeah yeah
it's like it's just a really really good
yeah Danny DeVito produced this he
produced a lot of movies in the 90s
which but yeah I thought that was kind
of cool yeah his little short ass maybe
maybe that's maybe that's why this movie
appealed to him
overcoming physical limitations
well he did that like a [__]
didn't he yeah they say he's like one of
the nicest guys in Hollywood just a
total normal guy yeah yeah
well yeah like I said I think this kind
of like the the mess the message of this
movie kind of like resonates with a lot
of people because
you know it just shows that I mean I was
watching this video before where a guy
was saying that he saw this when he was
younger and he said you know I was kind
of like uh chubby kid and these big coke
bottle glasses and all of a sudden he's
like so when I saw this movie it was
like really inspirational because I
thought hey that guy was kind of [__]
up and he but he like got over it like
he he went through and he like you know
fixed all his problems and because he
just wanted something so badly like he
had a goal in mind yeah and he said I'm
gonna [__] do that and he's like and
that was like really aspirational yeah
it wasn't free he just didn't cheat and
therefore he got there no he [__]
read all these books huge amounts of
[__] books
about physics and science of like and
went through a bunch of physical
training to pass all the dumb astronaut
[__] that he had to do remember that
he's doing pull-ups and [__]
gymnastics and stuff and he was doing it
with no money basically yeah and I mean
he had to put the work in he didn't have
all the advantages that the genetically
engineered people had yeah they didn't
really have to work at it right so he
had to work like way harder than them
like to get to the same place yeah so
like I said it's almost kind of like a
class struggle type of thing too like
you know people that are born really
wealthy and have everything handed to
them as opposed to somebody born really
poor without any advantages it's the
same trying to come up right it's like
the same kind of thing yeah Zach said
this movie does remind me a lot of how
picky people my age are when it comes to
dating and how frustrating it is
yeah I mean this is a little nightmarish
but you could like see this happening
though well what's funny is that it is a
Utopia but for the for a person of uh
who's not genetically engineered it's a
dystopia right but for the it's intended
to be it's not always the way yeah it's
Utopia for the genetically engineered
everybody else yeah they're having a
great time yeah the the non-engineered
being phased out and they're just like
you're the janitor now you know they're
just waiting for you to die off what
happens when all they die off then he's
going to be the janitors probably robots
robots that's what I was just gonna say
I think it was busy work
more than anything else yeah they were
just kind of like just they were just
keeping their eye on them and and
watching them leave watching them slowly
die off is what they were doing yeah I
guess so they just wanted to know where
they were
yeah that's what they would make sure
they're not getting up to any Mission
well would you let him just run around
right no yeah you have to give them like
something you'd have to have them give
them something to do and you'd have to
be accountability you'd have to know
where they where they are because they
would run amok in a society like the
Gattaca Society so you'd have to keep
them busy and that's what they're doing
yeah
initially
um Hugo said uh the island from 2005
also come to mind yeah that's kind of
similar uh as well this one
um actually this was uh the guy named
Andrew Nichol uh written directed this
and this was his directorial debut he
actually got the chance to do this
because he wrote where he wrote um The
Truman Show like a year or two of awards
which is a great movie another great
movie by the way uh if we because I
don't think we've covered that one
but um it's kind of a shame that this
movie really didn't do very well at the
box office but I feel like it's one of
those ones that was kind of like ahead
of its time I think it was and so now
it's become like a cult classic and it's
almost kind of one of those ones that
really kind of like seeped into the
cultural Zeitgeist like almost without
anybody noticing you know what I mean
something about the movies kind of
relaxing and kind of inspirational I
mean it's inspirational it's it it
it has kind of a bittersweet ending
where there's Triumph for one character
and kind of tragedy for the other
simultaneously yeah
which um
but at the end you end up
end up it ends up being kind of like a
feel-good movie
yeah I mean I found it that I found it
that and I really like I said I think we
just started talking about like the
relationship with him and his brother
one of the best lines in the movie and
actually Ethan Hawke has said uh in
interviews that this is one of the
favorite his favorite movies that he did
and he was like he it was a shame that
it didn't do better but that like you
know it's a cult classic now so that's
good but it was one of the favorite
movies that he had ever worked on and he
actually worked with Andrew nickel a lot
like uh subsequently in a lot of his
other movies later on yeah I wanna I
wanna actually own this one yeah I would
like to get the suck on steelbook yeah
that would yeah is there a steel book of
this there's got to be there's got to be
at this point but one of the best lines
in the movie is that
um there's kind of a thing where him and
his younger brother Anton they would do
like a swimming race like you know it
was like or it's more like a game of
chicken I guess really like who was
gonna chicken out first and for a long
time like when they were kids
um you know Vincent would always lose
because he was genetically inferior and
anti would always win but then there was
one day when they were teenagers when
Anton uh lost like he didn't get voice
and then he started to drown and then it
ended up that Vincent saved him and so
it was kind of this thing and then like
now that they're adults and they like
reconnect as adults and then they do the
same thing again and Anton loses again
and so he says to Vincent he's like well
how did you do all this he's not talking
about how did you beat me swimming how
did you get into Gattaca which is like
this big uh you know top kind of thing
how did you get in there and how did you
actually get to a point where you can
you're going into space and he says
something like Vincent says uh you know
how I did it he's like I never saved
anything for the swim back yeah that's
what he said just balls to the wall
do or die and it's like yeah and that's
it's like he just didn't worry about it
he's like that's I I he had his eyes on
the prize and he had a goal and he just
like worked as hard as possible just to
get to it he didn't worry about like
yeah Gattaca is a space
company I guess you guess it's kind of
like SpaceX
um they were launching they were
launching Rockets every few hours going
to other planets and other worlds yeah
they were all in the solar system I I
believe I believe they're all in the
solar system yeah I think they're
basically just going to like moons like
planets and stuff so um
and uh but another thing is
g-a-t-c or or is the [__] the four
proteins that make technically a bases
yeah the nucleotide or the the yeah the
the of your DNA yeah
so that's that's kind of a
tricky kind of a cool name yeah a movie
for the movie and where he was working
originally the movie was supposed to be
called The Eighth Day you know because
like the seven days of creation or
whatever but then like they found out
that there was like a foreign movie that
was coming out the same time and it was
called The Eighth Day so they had to
change it but gattica is a great name I
mean I I really really like that uh
basically DNA yeah DNA that's what it
means yeah and there's a lot of like
symbolic because like even in like in
Jerome's apartment like he has that
spiral staircase that looks like a DNA
thing yeah it's pretty cool symbolism in
it yeah Zach says also can we talk about
the upside down sex scene
yeah that's right it was like it was uh
Uma Thurman and Ethan Hawke it was like
well it was in her apartment and I'm
watching it I'm like well is that a
because it looked like her house was
like this had a glass wall right and
then it was like right on the then the
ocean or like the beach was like right
up there I was like is that a screen
like showing something or is that a
window or what is that like I couldn't
figure it out it was under the
impression that the walls were glass
that the walls to her bedroom were glass
yeah she was living in a glass house
literally oh yeah maybe I'd never been
what they were talking about yeah yeah
yeah living in a glass house man they
just put they put a lot of thought into
this kind of stuff
um that was my interpretation I may be
wrong yeah but that's right no I think I
think you're right on the money there
yeah I think you're right on the money
though yeah but it was a beautiful house
it really was you better be an expert an
exhibitionist or not just give a [__] or
you live in a world where nobody really
cares because everybody's because they
were in there hitting it man
and they were the whole ocean was seeing
it the whole ocean yeah the whole ocean
all little dolphins and lobsters and
stuff like popping up going ooh yes
there was like [__] California
Highway 101 right out front of the front
door remember that yeah
so I guess you know this [__] was so
classy that you could just you know
have sex in full View and that [__] was
stylish
have fun people
wasn't any lewd [__]
meat jerkers or anything you know none
of those guys would appear nowadays he'd
be a bunch of bums out there
you're not in California
hold my wine
Ethan
[Laughter]
yeah with a little cute bob haircut
she brought the Bob back
well like I said they styled everyone in
this movie very much like a Noir film so
she looked very much like a classic like
New Year like she even had I think that
one scene where they go see The
12-fingered Pianist like she had that
that blonde that kind of Crest hair kind
of action going which was like awesome
and I was like I always wish I could get
my hair to do that but I don't I'd have
to have somebody else do that I don't
really know how they do that uh Zach
said also the cinematographer on this
movie worked with a great polish
director uh Kristoff kaislavski a lot on
his career which is really cool yeah one
of the I mean this is just a gorgeous
looking movie it does look a lot more
expensive than 36 million dollars to be
honest with you but
uh yeah the upside down sex scene that's
like really funny all right so um are we
are we done yeah yeah I just recommend
the flick man it's good flick you guys
would like it yeah I feel like a lot of
people maybe don't talk about it or life
lessons in it
yeah it's just like a really well done
like I said it's more it's allegorical
yeah you can think about it yeah like
more than super realistic and there it
doesn't give you like a timeline either
I think like it just says in the not too
distant future yeah it's just whenever
you want Sunday A.D for all you Misty
Misty's out there uh but yeah so
everybody should watch it it's really
really good
especially if you like sci-fi I feel
like Blade Runner or anything like that
like you'd probably dig it so tomorrow
is Monday that means It's haunting
Mondays yeah so you guys watch the
morning tonight so we got to do a
haunting um like I said you know it's
gonna be later we're probably not gonna
start till 7 30 because you know of work
schedules and things like that but I
think we are going to do because I was
looking through all the uh episodes
today and I was like hey there's a
season one episode it's episode four and
it's called cursed and I'm pretty sure
we haven't done that one so I think that
we're gonna do that one because I
thought we'd done all the season one
episodes but I was looking at that I was
like that does not look all that
familiar so but that doesn't mean like
it's
not a memorable episode it's just we saw
so many you know what I mean yeah so uh
so yeah so it'll be season one episode
four cursed is the one we're gonna do
and like I said it'll be a later start
it'll probably be 7 30 like before we
like Eastern Standard Time like before
we uh get into it but hopefully you guys
can all join us for that so you know uh
thanks for coming by and hanging out
with us on this Sunday evening and we'll
see you guys again tomorrow
good night